but then you look at it it hit i think
69 000 this year as the high bitcoin hit
do you think it's possible you mentioned
gold
do you think it's possible it reaches
very high numbers like 1 million some
people talk about
i don't i don't think that's possible
because the way i look at it is
there's a certain amount of
um certain amount of it
and there's a certain amount of gold
i'll use gold as a benchmark
the amount of it is worth about five uh
about one trillion dollars
total cryptos about 2.2 trillion but
let's say bitcoin uh it's one trillion
dollars
if you take the amount of money that is
in um
gold
that is not used for jewelry purposes
and not used by central banks and i
assume bitcoin won't be used for jewelry
purposes or central bank purposes
um that amount in gold is about five
trillion dollars
so right now if you were to
have a portfolio that has um gold and
crypto
um gold then bitcoin it's worth about 20
of the value of gold
do i think it's going to be
worth more than gold
in terms of that mix i don't think it'll
be worth more than gold but let's say it
became worth
as as much as gold i don't believe it
will be i think the 20
sounds kind of about right i really
don't know that what the right answer is
um and then there's the question of what
is all of that pool of money
that let's say gold and gold equivalents
relative to everything else does it go
from
you know let's call it
six seven eight trillion to sixteen
trillion maybe it could double it
depends what it is in the world
environment but basically if you use
gold as a measure i um there's no it
just makes no sense that it's going to
be used um
that much more
am i sure about that i'm not sure about
anything but logically it seems to me
that there's a limitation on its price
in relationship to other things that are
like it
you